do you I'm curious now at this age what
do you do because you look fantastic but
obviously you've probably CH completely
changed up your regimen because you have
different goals now so in the what do
you do when you get up in the
morning 6 605 606 you've had your vener
schnitzel
Pizza um you've made sure you've gone
online and checked in on con O'Brien
what he's up to you've listened to his
latest podcast that's all out of the way
you've watched some of my classic
clips now it's 8:00 9 o00 but you go to
workout what do you what do you do is
the goal now uh to try increase weights
do you want so everything that you said
is absolutely
true that's how my day starts the only
thing that you
forgot which is kind of like very
selfish thinking because you forgot my
animals oh you're right you see before I
watch
Conan and before listen to you I go and
feed Lulu and whiskey that's right and
then I feed Chelli which is my pig you
have a pig and then I have three dogs
you have three dogs yes and then then
and Lulu and schnit Lulu Lulu is is the
is the miniature donkey miniature donkey
and then and then and whiskey is the
miniature pony how did you get to have a
miniature donkey well my girlfriend gave
it to me okay that's the answer to most
things so I had I had whiskey which is
my daughter's miniature pony and uh and
my daughter's somewhat abandoned to this
whiskey mhm so you know we used to be
hanging out and taking her around and
everything like this on shows and and uh
walking with her and then all of a
sudden from one day to the next she
didn't do anything and this whiskey was
this miniature pony was down at the
stable down on mandville Canyon by
herself and no no one really did paid
attention it so I said to one of these
guys down there can you bring the
whiskey up to the house mhm and so I
have a big backyard I have 2 and a half
acres of flat ground and so he brought
whiskey up and so I had to run around up
there and then I brought it into the
kitchen I started feeding us some
cookies and some you know carrots and
all you have a pony in the kitchen yeah
there's a pony and a donkey in the
kitchen now you know now a few years
later my girlfriend says okay you cannot
have a pony alone it needs company so
she gets me for Christmas a miniature
donkey so I get this little miniature
donkey which was very young 9 months old
and they fell in love with each other
and they hang out together now they both
come into the house in the morning so
when I get up in the morning and they
get them out of the stable at 6: in the
morning they come into the kitchen and
they feed them cookies and that the pig
comes running are they supposed to be
eating cookies no is oatmeal cookies
oatmeal cookies I thought you were just
like here's an Oreo an Oreo for you an
Oreo for you now get the out of
here exactly I got those oatmeal
cookies I got these oatmeal cookies made
for myself because I didn't want to have
the regular commercial oatmeal cookies
with the sugar so she just make it with
honey and so they did so I have this big
jaw of oatmeal cookies so then all a
sudden so I was eating this cookie and
the horse was pushing me so I said let
me try it so I give it the cookie eating
it immediately then pushing me again so
I give her another cookie then I gave
her Lulu the cookie so all a sudden it
became a stick right now we make extra
cookies for the horses but the dogs sit
down next to me while the horses are
eating the cookies so now they're
begging and they're reaching up with
their paw so now giving cookies to the
dogs then the pig comes around and now
there's like all of them sitting there
and I'm just you know for for 10 minutes
handing out cookies or have to make
pounds and pounds of cookies every day
you are you're white Dr D Dr do little
Dr Hines do little yeah listen I don't
understand we're
talking so that's what I do so you know
con that's what I do before I listen to
your podcast I mean forist you can do it
while listening to the
podcast listen I don't understand I this
is the Delight of of Arnold trer is that
we're talking and I think well here's
what we're going to talk about is his
new body work bodybuilding regime at
this age now what do you do now and
before I know it you're in a room you're
basically in a keyboard elf tree making
cookies for pigs donkeys and ponies
that's right exactly it's Madness then I
go to the gym so now I drive down to the
beach do you ride the Little Pony no no
I no kidding me I have my my
grandchildren They Ride the pony and
they ride the the the miniature uh
donkey but I hold on to the kids because
you never know they're very feisty those
animals they obviously didn't charge and
run off and all this stuff so I want to
make sure that they're safe but the the
grandchildren love coming over to the
house and seeing all the animals
everyone of the grand kids has their
favorite animal you know can I see
Cherry can I see Chelli can I see Lulu
can I see this again so that's and then
what I do a lot of times is I have a
cousin that is 95 years old in New York
and he's kind of old and uh and so very
very fragile so what they doing I have
Al a a a
cousin by the name of Monica in Austria
so what I do a lot of times is while I'm
feeding the animals I go and dial their
number on my iPad and I film the whole
thing and they love it they talk about
it the entire day they just really love
it so people really get entertained with
that a lot of times people ask me can I
come over to your house and see the
animals not to see can I come and visit
you no no one is interested in that they
just want to go they just want to go and
see the animals and then they come over
to see the with the kids or whatever it
is p exactly that's right but anyway so
then I go down to the to the beach yeah
tell me what you do there bike off the
of my uh Yukon and then I drive uh to
Gold Gym then I work out 45 minutes at
Gorge gym and then I I ride back put my
bike back on a on a on a truck and then
drive home and have breakfast or have
nothing and then it just continue on
with my work I would love to work out
with you someday yeah and and you might
be surprised I might uh be in better
shape than you think I am you know I'm
just saying or you might be surprised
the other way that a man my age could
let himself go that much it could go
either way and why would I have to be
surprised in the first place that's true
what is your obsession about me being
surprised you're right I guess I'm
trying to impress you one way or the
other well that's okay even in the
positive way or the negative way I just
want to make some impression I want to
be the last thing you think of at night
before you say good night to so he wakes
up watching Conan and going to sleep
thinking about you after says good night
good night his vision that is his vision
it's unbelievable yeah I'm sorry what is
going on I need to be medicated and I am
medicated I just need more
medication